foreign
let's go to Brandon in Phoenix what's up
Brandon
hi John how are you remarkable how are
you
doing well doing well thanks for taking
my call you got it man what's up
uh so kind of a weird situation
um my wife and I recently moved here to
Phoenix a few months ago I started a
brand new job
um totally new city New State all of
that
um and over the past month and a half or
so
uh I've developed a really big crush on
a co-worker
and I feel like I'm yeah
yeah
I feel like I'm back in high school and
it's the it's it's a very weird feeling
uh I've been happily married for almost
four years and uh my marriage is great
and I don't know why all of a sudden
this has come up but it has and I'm not
sure how to navigate that hmm
Okay so
are you ready just to buckle up because
I got a lot of thoughts
okay here's your job your job is to
interrupt me at any point okay
okay is that cool
that's cool I'm gonna rock and roll you
tell me you're wrong hold on and just
yell throw a flag or if you have like
one of those shut up buttons just push
it okay
so sounds good four years in
y'all have started to settle in and then
you took a new job you'll move to a new
town it was exciting and scary and y'all
had to leave friends or family or
whatever and you landed here okay and
your wife has probably settled into
you're developing a routine you're
starting to talk about what house one
day and maybe having kids We're not
gonna have kids and all that stuff and
you're slowly slowly tiny slowly
feeling the old adventurous yeah dude
Brandon
slow you're starting to suffocate a
little bit and the humanity of your wife
is real she's got boogers and she farts
and she's like doesn't wear makeup all
the time like all that stuff
and
then you start this new job in this new
town
and somebody makes your heart start
beating a little faster again
and maybe her body's a little bit better
than your wives a little bit different I
would say better than but it's more your
jam or maybe there's something in the
way she touches your arm or she laughs
or she listens to the same music as you
there's a little thing that slowly makes
you feel like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
remember this guy the way he used to
feel around girls like her and you even
said it
uh you feel like a high schooler again
you know it was in high school for some
of us like me I loved it
I love the awkwardness I love wondering
if she liked me I wondered I loved when
she broke up with me I mean I hate it at
the time but in retrospect I love my
wife hated it I loved it dude and so let
me make this super clear to you okay
this is not about her
nothing to do with her this is about you
and I want to free you from something
being attracted to people thinking
people are awesome wondering what if I
would even go as far as to say is having
like a crush on so like I just like
spending time with it that's the rest of
your life dude and I'm not I I think
anybody who beat you up over that is an
idiot okay
um okay but
yeah let me say this but you're always
going to find people that are sexy or
beautiful hilarious fun I had one friend
tell me um he ended up leaving his wife
right so and we'll get to that in a
second
but he said something I Just Like the
Way She Moves
and there was a sensuality to where this
this person he worked with the way she
just moved through the world right it
wasn't even this particular I'm
overwhelmed by how beautiful she is or
whatever whatever
so whatever that is you land on two
choices okay you ready
Choice number one
I am going to scratch and fight and Claw
my way back to feeling alive inside the
marriage that I committed my life to
and we'll talk about that in a second
how you do that but we're going to
create a world where I feel alive where
I'm daily leaning into my wife where I
tell her the truth where I tell her what
I would love to try in the bedroom where
I would like to stop doing like when it
comes to holiday plans all this I'm
gonna start telling her the truth
because I haven't really been I've been
hoping she's a mind reader and kind of
leaning in a little bit and hoping she
would pretend and kind of trying to
position her this way but I haven't said
anything because I'm kind of dishonest
and kind of a coward a little bit and
I'm gonna allow her to say the same
thing too I'm gonna respect her
boundaries
so I'm going to stop there before I get
to number two am I off by in on any of
this
no uh actually just kind of describing
the situation you you've pretty much
nailed it on the head and and I I want
to clarify yeah like I'm I'm in a great
marriage I I love my wife uh but yeah I
think I don't know just something about
starting in this new place and uh and I
don't even have that that close of a
relationship with this co-worker it
literally just being friends at work but
uh yeah she's this co-worker definitely
has me feeling some of those things so
okay I think I think you're right on so
that leads me to number two
okay you're gonna respect the fact that
you stood up
in front of your friends and your family
and if you're a person of faith in front
of God
and you stood before her
your wife
and you said come what comes I will be
right here
yeah what that means is
when you have crushes and want to hang
out more and want to have a little side
text conversation with somebody
I have been there across the board on
all those things dude
and I've accidentally
through private jokes and thinking this
is funny found myself staring over an
abyss
with no intention see what I'm saying
yeah thank God I've never done anything
irreversible but I'm telling you it's
just so innocuous and my whole life
was about flirty energy that's how he
entered a room
and I'm telling you right now it's it's
been an off switch now I enter a room
with peace and I don't want anything
from any of the people because what I
realized I was using people to make
myself feel better okay so the earlier
you can say
yeah she's beautiful
she's hilarious and I'd like to there it
is that's when you got a choice
I don't I just don't I don't text women
I'm not married to
I don't go get drinks with fill in the
blank anymore I don't do this anymore I
make sure I sit over here
because I told my wife
and it's gonna feel like
um
I mean gosh now you're gonna get me all
so boxed out we just live in a culture
that's just like your feelings are the
most important thing and I reject that
with all of my heart
because you have the same feelings that
point out how much how pretty she is and
how funny she is or whatever that you're
finding attractive about her
those same feelings pointed you towards
your wife like feelings are feelings and
then you made a choice right and so
action I think is really critical here
um okay
[Music]
what are you gonna do
well I I I have been meaning to really
talk about it with my wife I'm a little
nervous as to how she'll react what
would that bring you
um well I mean I I think for me it would
bring me peace but yeah I am a little
anxious as to what she'll have you done
anything have you done anything wrong
no
what is man now I'm going to get myself
in some dangerous territory
what I've found with younger Millennials
is uh and it's it's a real and I say
that not in a disparaging way I just
don't see it in other other generational
groups is a need to over over share
an almost weaponized transparency
what I mean by that is
um
I tell people all the time you can't
keep secrets like you gotta be honest
with your spouse you got to tell them
what you're what's going on you got to
tell them like all that's good and I'm
finding people who are 22 23 25 26
walking down the mall and looking over
at their husband and being like man I'd
like to sleep with that guy and it's
like that's super not helpful right
there's a point when it's it so that's
what I'm asking you what what about this
situation you're at a new job in a new
town in a new place
maybe you didn't want to take this new
job maybe this is mostly the house that
your wife picked maybe you're starting
to settle in and say oh my gosh this is
the rest of my life and I don't like who
I'm becoming and then I see her
what makes you say I need to go tell my
wife that I found somebody else
attractive
well
I uh I don't know I I think it's just
wanting to be transparent with my wife
uh you know I've always been and um I
yeah I guess I'm just afraid of maybe
you know triggering some anxiety some
jealousy in her
um will you ever cheat on your wife
sorry will you ever cheat on your wife
no okay
if I was you I would probably I would
consider a couple of things one yes if I
mean you know your marriage better than
me if sitting down saying I need you to
know that I have the feelings for
somebody at work and I don't even hear
you saying you have feelings for
somebody I have you I feel like you're
telling or I hear you telling me I'm
kind of caught off guard because I'm
kind of got a crush on somebody which is
different than I I really I'm trying to
figure out ways to spend more time with
somebody I really want somebody else
does it make sense and it sounds like
I'm being I'm dancing a fine line here
but if you tell me if I'm wrong yeah
um
let me give you this picture Esther
perel paints and I love it
you spend all of your dating time
practicing safety
is she gonna show up is he gonna answer
the phone
if somebody tries to like get me in a
bar is he gonna stand up for me like
we're practicing safety
and you're LED all with desire can't
wait to be together you blow off tests
you skip work you're making out in the
middle of dinner like right I mean it's
it's all about desire
then when you begin to establish safety
it's very difficult for desire to remain
in the presence of safety
right that's uh that's that's settling
in
what we don't have in our culture we do
have the practice safety you'll hear
your friends being like hey do you does
does he call you back does did she
listen to you and you were telling her
that you were sad like we have those
conversations we don't have the other
conversations which are
how do I create a world where we're both
Fully Alive and there's mystery and
romance and all-day text exchanges that
lead into firework shows right and right
you see what I'm saying so
I think the best way to start this
conversation is we just started a whole
new life in a new town with a new job
and I find myself on a trajectory where
I don't like who I'm becoming
and my guess is it's not just related to
this person at work that you feel like a
high schooler around my guess is you're
probably also avoiding X not helping
around the house a little bit maybe
taking one more drink than you normally
do or eating one more Taco than you
normally do am I wrong on any of those
um I I wouldn't say I I I've actually
been really trying to work on myself
better just hitting the gym more and
things like that
um and right there's the challenge can I
tell you that I know that I know I'm
going against everything that you're
going to see on Instagram for the next
five months I know that
when y'all lock into a new town in a new
place and a new adventure and a new part
of your life
you each going your separate ways to
quote unquote work on yourselves can
actually pull you all further apart
you may end up spending more time in the
gym but the only way this thing works
long term is if you all decide we're
doubling down on who we're gonna be
together
right and so your whole life is
different and you'll probably have not
called that out yet
your old marriage is over your old
College time is over your old high
school time is over you're in a new town
in a new state and a new job and a new
whatever
and so
you all have to acknowledge we're
building a new world
and right part of our new world is we
take care of ourselves cool I need to go
to the gym see what I'm see how
different that is than I've been working
on myself listening to podcasts going to
the gym
um do it like journaling more all of
those things are isolating you further
and further and further from the person
that you're supposed to be building a
life with
okay yeah
and you may end up doing those same
things I hope I don't sound crazy you
may end up doing those same exact things
but they're going to be in service to
your marriage not in service to you just
getting better so you can crush and kill
and I'm I'm becoming more and more
outspoken I think we've just missed it
as a culture uh Brandon I'm not I'm not
picking on you now I'm just talking to
everybody
somewhere along the way we begin telling
people you shouldn't be married you
shouldn't get in relationships until
you're all you and if you're struggling
with like a mental health disorder or
you've got some major personality
challenges yes you need to go make sure
you're well
or if you're codependent marrying
somebody so that you can be okay is
never healthy but this idea that I've
got to go be a Spartan and you've got to
be a Spartan so that we can then get
married is madness
you got to do that stuff together in
service of one another I'm not going to
crush it and kill it in my 20s so I can
crush it and killed it in my so I can
have crushed and killed in my 20s I'm
gonna crush it and kill it in my 20s
because me and my wife have a vision of
what our family tree is going to look
like when the dust settles on our life
and I'm willing to put all that work in
I'm willing to do this and x and y and
sacrifice on behalf of my wife and my
kids and my community and my country and
my wife is I'm willing to put this aside
and this aside and that goes right in
the face of you follow your dreams and
you follow your dreams when somebody
tells me these words this is the new
magic words
um
our marriage just ran its course
bullcrap I call BS I called BS
one of you quit or what both of you quit
or one of you did something that the
other person said I can no longer be a
part of this
but the idea that a relationship just
naturally runs out of gas is false
people make life changes people move
people make decisions about how they're
going to invest in themselves and other
people and and more importantly in the
total relationship
so Brandon I tell you a lot to tell you
I love you you're not crazy I don't
think you're a bad guy I don't think you
need to walk in your front door and be
like I am
I I I don't hear that okay I also you
you if you listen to the show for five
seconds you know I'm really anti-secrets
right it may be that when you tell your
wife hey I'm even finding myself like
having crushes on people at work like I
I I'm worried about
um I'm worried about my trajectory
and I want to create a world where we
desire one another
um and we practice desire on a regular
basis
um
I want you to know you're not crazy
I've been there I don't know actually uh
anybody that hasn't been there male or
female quite honestly
questions what are you gonna do
are you gonna do what the culture says
and follow your feelings and they're
gonna lead you right off a cliff
or are you gonna remember I made a
covenant I said till death do us part
all my things are your things and all
your things are my things
and I'll spend the rest of my life
making sure your life is well and I hope
you'll do the same for me
I think you should choose option two but
that's just me